i made a whole documentary about it
the first night of those shows was a
piece that some of you might have seen
it was called 846 and have dealt with
the death
the murder
of george floyd
[Applause]
this film that i made was invited to
every film festival in the united states
and some of those invitations i accepted
and when this controversy
came out
about the close-up
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals and now
today
not a film company not a movie studio
not a film festival nobody will touch
this film thank god for teds randalls
and netflix he's the only one that
didn't cancel me yet
to the transgender community i am more
than willing
to give you an audience
but you will not summon me i am not
bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to but i have some
conditions
[Applause]
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end
[Applause]
you must come to a place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly
you must admit
that hannah gatsby is not funny
[Applause]
[Laughter]
ah that [ __ ] gets me every time i don't
know nanette if you aren't aware of
ganna gatsby she's a community from uh
i believe australia who did a netflix
special was lauded by the lgbt community
as well as like a lot of critics in the
industry because it was very progressive
and shed light on the plight of being
she trans
i know she's some
so and again non-binary i don't know i'm
not going to make the time to google
that [ __ ] but anyways just so you know
that's why he's referring to her because
she came out and said dave chappelle's a
tran
basically called him anti-trans so
[Applause]
i desperately want people to see this
movie
but i understand why investors would be
nervous since nobody will touch it i'll
tell you what i'll do
i will make it available
for all of you in 10 american cities
going on sale in the next few days you
will be able to see this movie in its
entirety and you can see what they're
trying to obstruct you from seeing
and you can judge for yourself but you
cannot have this conversation
and exclude my voice from it
that is only fair
you have to answer the question am i
canceled or not
then let's go thank you very much and
good night
yeah yeah every time i see this man this
man is destroying mike's but he has to
throw the mic money so yeah
as he throws the mic he throws that ball
yeah um
so as a result of him and his special as
well as all the controversy surrounding
it uh it seems as though his movie's
being stunted in terms of growth and
availability to people on the flip side
dave chappelle has become the focal
point between this conversation this
kind of boiling point that's been
happening between the lgbtq the trans
community and the rest of the population
yeah there is definitely a big divide
that's been there yeah and dave
chappelle with his priority high
high nameless status and the way he came
about this discussion has definitely put
himself at the front and center of it
now yeah definitely i think that's why
this story hasn't gone away from the
news for two weeks now yeah yeah it's
still there there's back and forth there
is response there's all of that and yeah
and he's
and he's doubling down and they're
doubling down so it's it's a it's a not
a conversation it's a back and forth
you can have it back and forth but not a
conversation but anyway i digress my
personal thoughts on it
um i think this is going to be great for
his brand
um i think since his inception since he
started he's always um
in a way not gone with what the industry
and the corporations have wanted even
though he's being backed by netflix you
remember when he left uh comedy central
and he wouldn't bend a lot of people
respected him for this and a lot of
people irrespective of like whether or
not you think he's authentic or not
that's not the point people are going to
love him for this stance as well because
they see corporations as being aligned
with the lgbtq in a lot of ways bending
the knee to them all the time and what
they desire what they want and so
yeah people are going to see this man as
a hero they're going to go watch this
[ __ ] in droves they're going to buy
tickets at no matter the price and he's
going to be very profitable but he will
be shunned by i think a lot of aspects
of the industry maybe we'll see maybe
after this blows over it won't be the
case but i think this one's definitely
the biggest blow-up he's had so far
my personal stance i
am also personally really
over
lgbtq people just dominating the
conversation and telling other folks
what they can or can't say yeah or
telling folks if you say this we'll make
sure you're going to pay
i'm over that so for me i support
anybody who's going to go against that
so that's my kind of general thoughts on
the whole thing i think i've been over
that kind of way of thinking in that
rhetoric from for a while even with the
black lives matter stuff i was
over with that yeah like yo
that's not how we have a conversation
by people shutting the [ __ ] up or people
not being able to speak yeah you know
what i mean so i've been over that for a
while so it's just the same thing that
repeats itself yeah the same i'm not
for or against i'm like this side of
that side i don't think the point of it
and the way the the the
to really go about it is really by
choosing a side but really by listening
to everybody's point and having a
discussion and people don't want to have
discussions and [ __ ] so that's really
the main thing to me yeah have a [ __ ]
discussion yeah so
you know i saw an article today that
said that kyrie irving and dave
chappelle are pawns of the white man and
the white corporations it's crazy that's
weird because it's really the opposite
that's going on well the corporations
the corporations are
are not [ __ ] with that they're using
they're actually using lgbtq
you're going you go in june yeah all you
see is rainbow flags which they i don't
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just that i know that it's corporation
just knowing where the money is and
being like you know we want to look like
we're nice and appealing to people that
are they want people to buy this [ __ ] so
it's weird that's weird they also said
that the the very people who are
supporting you right now wouldn't defend
you if anything happened meaning like
it's probably going to be trump
supporters who are going to support dave
chappelle and i can assure you when it
comes to this sentiment towards lgbtq
people especially gay folks for example
that's not a a right-wing trump like
listen black folks in general have
always had
a certain sentiment towards gay people
period okay
this idea that all the views that
black folks have that somehow
mirror white conservatives is a result
of trying to appeal to them is nonsense
i think
whenever an individual comes out and
says something that may not be popular
with certain groups or
when a minority speaks out in a way that
a lot of other folks don't like what
ends up happening is that people are
like oh well you're just eight yeah
you're just catering you are
brown-nosing you are
you know doing this for using clicks
right that's really just for your best
advantage maybe it's really something
that you're being used by the it's like
listen irrespective of who end up
following me at the end of the day
whether that crowd changes or doesn't
i'm going to say what i believe to be
true
all right and guess what some people
can't operate on that
me personally if i say something and
then it happens to align with a lot of
right-wing viewers i don't give a [ __ ]
personally right the same way when i
said stuff about police officers during
those rights and things like that i
didn't care that the right folks got mad
because i don't give a [ __ ] you should
have your views and it shouldn't matter
who's necessarily supporting you if
that's what you look at
to decide
whether or not somebody's stance is
valid or not then we're wasting our
times with these discussions because
it's not about what you're saying or the
substance of the argument it's about
well who likes your argument they're
looking they're looking at this the same
way i was looking at wrestling when i
was a kid
when i was a kid and was look i was
looking at ray wrestling of course there
was the good that was the bad of course
you wanted to be good you i wanted to be
a good guy and so you all were always
rooting right rooting for for the good
guy you were like you know what that's
the good guy i'm with that hulk hogan
and all that but anything you realize
this bad guy is a badass
i there's something about that that i
like good guy bad guy left right
everybody's a bad guy to the other guy
what's his perspective
what's his point of view you know what i
mean
and as i got older i like what i like
if i like a person that happens to be
a bad guy i'm gonna like that if but no
somebody's like no they're good i like
it all good and everything that they do
is all good on one side and it's not
really that that's not really life
that's not what really happens right you
want to do the good or the better the
food you are if we believe this is being
better
everybody's a bad guy for another person
cobra kai do i think that dave chappelle
can be canceled of course not so long as
they have the support of the people you
can say whatever you want the
corporations can the people are going to
support them with their own personal
money because they really believe in his
values irrespective of whether he's as
funny as he used to be or whatever other
stuff you want to say that's the truth
he represents something symbolically
that's bigger than stand-up comedy at
the moment i think just folks are tired
i think folks are exhausted of a lot of
this activism nonsense that they see
happening a lot of these what they
perceive as like college campus
ideologies right where it's like super
liberal nonsense and ideas like silence
is violence like shut up right people
are sick of it
and so irrespective of whether or not
his stance are good or not so many
people are going to support him because
they're sick of that nonsense and this
is both left and the right
so me when i see
the talks of d platforming him the talks
of like demanding netflix stop
supporting him and put the money to
trans folks i'm like this is only going
to backfire in a major way for you guys
more and more people are getting tired
of it and it's not going to stop
as for dave he's going to be fine he
already made all his bread from netflix
he's going to be touring for a long time
just based off of the social currencies
gathered from speaking out on these
issues and now his voice is so important
he can choose and pick his spots and
talk about whatever topic he wants they
don't even come to the show expecting
jokes most of the time they just want to
hear the man speak that's pretty much
been my thoughts what do you got to say
playing yeah i'm not going to repeat all
right well let us know what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from you
what do you think